28. it's going to get windy again you
guys sherry's off today so we're keeping
an eye on this beautiful camera on top
of black mountain way down in the
southeast valley looking across at the
strip some lingering high cloudiness men
you can even see resorts world of course
the high rollover at the lake officially
we're hanging at 80 degrees same numbers
an hour ago that's 11 degrees warmer
than 24 hours ago the wind is now out of
the south at 11 but it's going to nearly
triple that but the time we get through
we're going to check your neighborhoods
here in a few minutes national weather
service going ahead and issuing what
they call that red flag or fire weather
warning high temperatures
strong winds and low humidity combining
to create fire danger both today and for
tomorrow we're talking about more wind
as we warm up and get into the upper 90s
let's talk about the weather headlines
wind off and on through tomorrow night
warmest temperatures of the year ahead
next week that will be in the 8 day
forecast we're going to check on how
little rain we've had so far this year
but let's get you hour by hour we're
going to gain back a couple of degrees
with winds maybe to 15 miles an hour
picking up to 20 miles an hour 92 at
noon mid 90's at 3 with winds to 25
maybe 30 miles an hour afternoon high of
98 will bring it back down to 96 by 6
this evening